Und nun im Programm der Rasenfunk.
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen im Rasenfunk. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf mastodon.social. Und jetzt auch auf Blue Sky. Das ist aber ein anderes Thema. Was ihr hier gerade gehört habt, ist nicht so klar zu erkennen, waren Szenen vom abgebrochenen Spiel zwischen Ajax Amsterdam und Feyenoord Rotterdam. Erst Szenen aus dem Spiel. Da wurden Bengalos während des laufenden Spiels aufs Feld geworfen. Das Spiel wurde unterbrochen oder abgebrochen erst mal. Es wird jetzt dann wieder neu nachgespielt. Und danach konnte man hören, wie ein privates Handy-Video es akustisch begleitet, dass sich Ajax-Fans Zugang zur Geschäftsstelle gemacht haben mit Gewalt und dort eingedrungen sind. Also da ist einiges los bei Ajax Amsterdam. Deswegen jetzt eine besondere Folge der Ligatour. Und ich bin sehr froh, einen perfekten Gast dafür zu haben. Es gibt bei Twitter ein fantastisches Projekt. Oranje Fußball. Alles, was ich über die Ehre Divisie weiß. Es ist nicht genug, ich weiß. Aber alles kommt von diesem Account. Denn Twitter nutze ich ja noch lesend. Bitte, bitte kommt zu Mastodon. Es wäre ganz wichtig. Und jetzt ist einer von ihnen hier. Es ist ein ganzes Team, das diesen Account bespielt. Benjamin Denes ist hier. Hallo Benny, schön, dass du da bist.
Hallo, vielen Dank für die Einladung.
Ja, sag uns doch kurz, bevor wir mit Ajax auch ein bisschen unangenehme Themen besprechen müssen, sag uns doch mal ein paar Dinge zu dir, zu Oranje Fußball, wo man euch überall verfolgen kann.
Ja, wir sind vier und sind so ein bisschen paritätisch besetzt, zumindest was die großen Antipoden im niederländischen Fußball anbelangt. Also Ajax und Feyenoord, das ist ja eine Rivalität wie BVB, Schalke, Celtic Rangers. Ein absoluter Klassiker, sagen die Niederländer auch, wenn die gegeneinander spielen. Und Andre ist Teil unseres Teams, der ist Riesen-Feyenoord-Fan. Andre ist auch tatsächlich der einzige Niederländer. Das ist ein Riesenvorteil, weil wir natürlich sehr viele niederländische Medien, Blogs, Twitter-Accounts, Scan-Videos anschauen. Andre guckt auch immer die Spiele im niederländischen Fernsehen, wo man noch mal ganz andere Hintergrundinfos und Interviews bekommt. Ja, und Niklas, Daniel und ich, also ich kümmere mich meistens um Ajax. Ich sage es auch gleich, ich bin zwar im Hauptberuf Journalist, aber hier, auch in deiner Sendung und auch auf Oraniefußball bin ich schon auch immer parteilisch. Wir kennzeichnen allerdings auch die Meinung. Ich bin Ajax-Fan seit 1987, versuche einmal im Jahr oder regelmäßig, einmal im Jahr ist es zu ambitioniert, aber ich versuche regelmäßig auch im Stadion zu sein. Ich hatte diese Saison das Glück. Ich muss mal überlegen, den einzigen Ligasieg, ja es war der einzige Ligasieg von Ajax im Stadion zu sehen, am ersten Spieltag gegen Aufsteiger Heracles. Und da war ich noch total optimistisch. Tja, und jetzt ist es seit ich Ajax-Fan bin, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, seit 1987 wirklich der Tiefpunkt. Ich bin vorsichtig mit Superlatives, aber es ist jetzt quasi hoffentlich der Ground Zero. Man weiß ja nicht, was noch kommen kann.
Ja, ganz kurz zu deiner persönlichen Geschichte noch. Wie wird man 87 Ajax-Fan, das war ja dann noch vor den großen europäischen Zeiten, oder verwechsel ich da noch mal?
Ja, das ist ein gutes Stichwort europäisch. Es ist irgendwie eine bescheuerte und unprätentiöse Geschichte, aber als Sohn einer alleinerziehenden Mutter habe ich mich quasi selbst vor dem Fernseher für Fußball sozialisiert. Ich bin in Berlin aufgewachsen und habe 1987 das Europapokalfinale, der Pokalsieger Laike, wer es noch kennt, zwischen Lok Leipzig und Ajax Amsterdam, damals im DDR-Fernsehen verfolgt. Ich glaube, diese Charakteristischen Trikots und diese multi-ethnische Mannschaft, die Ajax damals schon war, hat mich total fasziniert. Dann war Van Basten schon im Kader, der junge Frankreicher, Sonny Siloie. Ich will jetzt hier nicht so Oper erzählen vom kriegmäßiges Name-Dropping machen, aber da fing es an und von da an habe ich sie immer verfolgt. Mein bester Freund hat später auch in Amsterdam gelebt. Wir haben das zusammen durchlebt und dann kamen ja sehr, sehr gute Zeiten. Louis van Gaal, aber auch natürlich die Zeit zuletzt mit Erik Ten Haag.
Ja, womit wir damit eigentlich schon ganz gut dann im Hier und Jetzt gelandet sind. Ich denke, manche höheren Noteure haben schon so grob mitbekommen, da ist was los bei Ajax und jetzt vor allem dieser Spielerbruch. Ich fühle mich ein bisschen schlecht, weil eigentlich möchte ich das nicht machen, immer nur dann zu vereinen und liegen zu gucken, wenn was richtig richtig schiefgeht. Bei Ajax habe ich aber jetzt schon seit vielen Monaten das Gefühl gehabt, da baut sich irgendwie was auf und entweder entlädt es sich positiv und jeder Mislintat-Transfer greift und sie werden überragend Meister oder es kommt so, wie es jetzt ist, nämlich dass es sportlich eine totale Misere geworden ist. Lass mal kurz bei diesem Spiel vorgestern anfangen, dass heute, wir nehmen am Dienstag den 26. September auf, sogar noch fertig gespielt werden soll. So eine Entscheidung, die ich persönlich sehr überraschend fand. Ich weiß nicht, wie du das siehst. Erklär uns mal kurz, was ist denn da passiert jetzt im letzten Klassiker? Es ist ja sowieso schon so, Gästefans sind schon seit ein paar Jahren nicht mehr dabei bei diesem Spiel.
Ja, und zwar in beiden Städten sozusagen. Das ist ein Hochrisikospiel und man muss sagen, es ist in dem Fall auch wirklich zum Teil lebensgefährlich. Es gab auch schon Tote bei Auseinandersetzung, schwere Ausschreitungen. Die Bürgermeister bzw. Bürgermeisterinnen, Bürgermeister der Städte, sind da auch immer sehr hinterher. Das ist leider gerechtfertigt, auch wenn es natürlich für die Stimmung im Stadion vielleicht noch besser wäre, wenn Ultras von beiden Seiten da wären. Gerade die Fans der Ultras machen auch eine Wahnsinnsstimmung. Die Stimmung am Samstag, Entschuldigung, beim Klassiker, war eigentlich super in der Arena. Ich habe auch noch getwittert, knallige Choreo. Also es gab so ein paar Feuerwerkskörper am Anfang, aber die Stimmung war wirklich magisch. Also das habe ich lange nicht mehr so erlebt. Die Zuschauer standen hinter dem Team, was nicht selbstverständlich ist, weil die Auftritte wirklich desaströs waren. Vor allen Dingen die beiden Spiele. Naja, das Spiel gegen Marseille war so ein bisschen besser. In Europa liegt davor, aber gegen Twente in der Liga, das war schon ein desaströser Auftritt eine Woche vorher. Die Niederlage, nicht die Niederlage an sich, aber das Auftreten. Also die Stimmung war gut. Ajax kam auch gut ins Spiel, muss man sagen, die ersten Minuten. Das war zum ersten Mal seit der Neue Trainer. Da ist so was wie eine Spielidee sichtbar. Nicht unbedingt eine Ajax-typische, aber immerhin. Man hat gesehen, aha, die haben jetzt gearbeitet, die hatten ein paar Trainingseinheiten, was ja auch wichtig ist bei so vielen neuen Spielern. Ich war eigentlich total optimistisch. Mitten da rein kommt ein wirklich ganz schwerer Fehler, eines der Neuzugänge, Anton Gaj, ein dänischer Rechtsverteidiger, junger Mann, bei dem ich mich auch gefragt habe, warum der so ein Spiel von Anfang an spielt. Aber gut, dann hat besagter Gaj, fünf oder zehn Minuten später einen F-Jugend-Fehler gemacht, quer Pass, vor dem eigenen Strafraum, über 20 Meter, Santi Grimines, der Torjäger von Feyenoord, holt sich den Ball, macht ganz easy, locker sein zweites Tor. Da steht es nach zehn oder zwölf Minuten. 2-0 für Feyenoord. Es ist so viel passiert, dass ich es jetzt gar nicht genau in der Abfolge rekonstruieren kann. Dann fiel ein Bierbecher aufs Feld oder an den Rand des Feldes. Das ist etwas, was in den Niederlanden eigentlich jede Woche passiert, was zu einer Unterbrechung führt. Die haben eine neue Regelung. Der Verband hat gesagt, er ist der Bierbecherwurf, der Schiri unterbricht. Manchmal holt er die Mannschaften vom Feld, manchmal, also meistens holt er die vom Feld. Dann wird noch mal angepfiffen und wenn der zweite Bierbecher fällt, die Niederländer nennen es auch Jubelbecher, dann wird das Spiel abgebrochen und meistens entscheidet dann der Verband, dass es ohne Zuschauer in den nächsten Tagen, also schnellstmöglich, zu Ende gespielt wird. Das ist eine ganz umstrittene Regelung. Bei Ajax war es so, dass der Bierbecher noch gar nicht der Auslöser war. Der Schiri hat das Spiel nur unterbrochen, weil er wollte, dass der Mensch aus dem Stadion entfernt wird. Und dann hat die F-Side einen Teil der Ajax Ultras, das sind so zwei große Gruppen. Die F-Side ist die, sagen wir mal, etwas radikalere, vielleicht auch aktivere. Die hat dann angefangen Richtung Timon Wellenreuther, oder zumindest in den Strafraum, nicht direkt auf ihn, muss man sagen, schon mit Abstand Bengalos zu werfen. Dann ist das Spiel unterbrochen worden, die Mannschaften sind in die Kabine gegangen, das Spiel ist wieder angepfiffen worden, und es hat gar nicht lange gedauert. Im Zwischenstand ist 0 zu 3, und das Spiel ist abgebrochen worden. Absolut alternativlose Entscheidung. Und wie du gesagt hast, du hast dich gewundert, dass es jetzt weiter gespielt wird, morgen Mittwoch, also morgen, wir sind jetzt am Dienstag, Mittwoch um 14 Uhr. Das ist doppelt kurios, weil –also erstens, Feyenoord wollte ein 3-0-Sieg und nicht mehr weiterspielen. Denn die haben viele Spiele, sie sind jetzt in der Champions League, für die ist das ein Thema. Ajax sollte Mittwochabend eigentlich ein anderes Spiel spielen, ein verschobenes von einem der frühen Spieltage gegen Fohlen-Damm. Da wiederum regt sich jetzt der Präsident auch darüber auf, will den Verband verklagen wegen Wettbewerbsverzeihung. Es ist ein absolutes Chaos. Man muss sagen, jetzt mal abseits von Ajax, Ajax ist eh in einer epochalen Krise, aber der niederländische Fußball ist auch insgesamt leider in einer Krise mit Fans. Ich bin niemand, der auf Fans draufhaut, ganz und gar nicht wirklich selber als einer bezeichnen, wenn ich jetzt auch nicht der Riesen-Ultra bin. Aber die Niederländer sind wahnsinnig euphorisch, wenn sie zum Fußball gehen, auch in den kleinen Stadien. Das macht echt total Spaß. Aber es kann nicht sein, dass jede Woche Spiele unter- oder abgebrochen werden, weil irgendein Hirni mit seinem Bierbecher das machen kann. Das sind Leute, die viel zu viel Macht bekommen. Und das ist, glaube ich, auch psychologisch der völlig falsche Weg. Und der Verband wird jetzt auch wohl eine Taskforce einberufen. Die Bürgermeisterin von Amsterdam hat jetzt auch die Politik aufgerufen, dass sie da was macht. Denn man sieht ja auch –das fand ich besonders erschreckend –welche Gewalteskalation dann von den Ajax Ultras gegen ihre eigene –nach ihrer Vereinsikone Johann Kreuf benannte –Arena passierte. Du hast die Ausschnitte am Anfang gespielt. Die wollten den Haupteingang stürmen. Sie haben ihn gestürmt. Jay Horta, der Torwart von Ajax zum Beispiel, hat gesagt, dass er um seine schwangere Freundin wirklich Todesangst hatte. Und Jay Horta ist selbst ein bisschen eine manuell neuer Geschichte. Der war auch Ultra. Also der ist niemand, der jetzt da schnell kritisiert. Und da wurden natürlich auch ein bisschen Erinnerungen an Schalke wach und an diese Jagd-Szene. Ich glaube, das geht gar nicht. Und da muss der Verein handeln, da muss der Verband handeln und ich glaube auch die Politik.
Aber war denn das –das ist jetzt natürlich rein spekulativ –aber war das denn auch das Ziel der Fans, wirklich zur Mannschaft zu gelangen und zu den Spielern? Ging es nicht eher darum, den größtmöglichen Aufschlag zu machen, um einfach diesen Frust zu kennzeichnen?
Also es ist Spekulation. Es gibt zwei Indizien. Die haben ja Transparente hochgehalten. Und die richteten sich ganz deutlich gegen den RWC, also wenn man das sieht, RVC. Das ist niederländisch für, ich spreche jetzt, ich verstehe niederländisch, meine Aussprache ist nicht perfekt, Rad von Van Gommissaren ungefähr, auf Deutsch Aufsichtsrat. Aufsichtsrat klingt jetzt erstmal so begleitend, das Gremium der Aufsichtsrat ist sehr mächtig. Und der ist im Prinzip das Hauptfeindbild der Fans. War es sogar noch mehr als wenn Mislintat, also Mislintat war dann auch in Misskredit geraten, aber vor allen Dingen durch eine, ich finde schon, auch beispiellose Kampagne von einer niederländischen Boulevard-Zeitung, dem Telegraph. Lassen wir mal kurz, wir werden sicher über Mislintat noch ausführlich reden. Aber ich glaube, den Fans ging es tatsächlich darum, auch den Aufsichtsrat mit, ich sage es mal, körperlicher Präsenz, dem einen Rücktritt nahe zu legen. Denn das Leid von Ajax wird auch mit diesem Aufsichtsrat und vielen anderen Entscheidungen, die auch weit vor Sven Mislintat zum Beispiel oder vor Trainer Maurice Steinliegen in Verbindung gebracht. Ich habe teilweise das so gelesen, dass Leute das interpretiert haben, dass die Ajax-Fans einen Abbruch aus sportlichen Gründen provozieren wollten, also um den erzrivalen Feyenoord zu schaden. Da bin ich mir relativ sicher, das ist nicht das Hauptmotiv. Also darum ging es nicht, denn das wäre ja dann umso fataler, wenn sie damit sozusagen das sportliche Bild verzerren könnten. Ich glaube, es ging wirklich darum, die Verantwortlichen zur Rede zu stellen. Und ehrlich gesagt, wenn du dir die Bilder auch anguckst, es gibt auch einige andere Videos, die zum Glück gar nicht so veröffentlicht wurden, die aber dann einem Fan voran aufgetaucht sind. Das ist auch einfach blanker Hass. Also es sind Leute, ich weiß nicht, ob die zu viel gesoffen haben. Das ist alles auch nicht mehr so rational und schlimme Bilder.
Es sah nicht zielgerichtet aus, es waren einige wenige, die was gemacht haben, dann sind andere mit dazu. Also ohne das irgendwie relativieren zu wollen, aber es sah nicht aus wie so eine konzertierte Aktion.
Es gibt auch Streit in der Fanszene und die Supporters vereinigen. Die Fan-Vereinigung hat sich insgesamt davon auch ganz klar distanziert. Das war eines der wenigen glücklichen Statements, die Ajax gemacht hat. Insgesamt wirkt auch das Auftreten der Vereinsführung absolut, ich muss leider sagen fast erbärmlich, unsportlich, viel zu wenig selbstkritisch, auch zu wenig Demut gegenüber Fan-Ort, Rotterdam. Fan-Ort ist unser größter Rival, aber sie tun mir an der Stelle wirklich leid, weil sie sind Meister geworden, sie spielen wahrscheinlich den Klassiker ihres Lebens und sie werden um einen fairen, ehrlichen Sieg beraubt. Ajax hätte zum Beispiel, finde ich, einfach eine einfache große Geste, sie hätten einfach auch den Verband darum bitten können, wer hat das Spiel 0 zu 3? Wollten sie nicht da jetzt nachzutreten? Das ist der Grund, warum ich am Anfang gesagt habe, ich weiß gar nicht, ob das der Ground Zero ist oder ob noch schlimmere Sachen zu befürchten sind.
Also Fan-Ort hat schon 3 zu 0 geführt zum Moment des Abbruchs. Gleichzeitig, wenn ich schon sehe, der Aufsichtsrat ist die Zielscheibe der Fans, dann müsste ja der Aufsichtsrat auch diese Entscheidung treffen, beim Verband zu sagen, komm, wir schenken dieses Spiel ab. Ich sehe es eigentlich ähnlich wie du, ich könnte mir aber vorstellen, dass es quasi, wenn man in entscheidender Funktion ist bei Ajax, gerade vielleicht auch besonders schwierig ist, dann so eine auch intern unpopuläre Entscheidung zu treffen. Aber auch da spekulieren wir nur, deswegen lasst uns das Reich der Spekulationen verlassen. Wie weit müssen wir denn zurückgehen, um zu erklären, wie Ajax in diese Lage gekommen ist? Wäre es da ein guter Beginn mit Marc Overmaas zu beginnen, dem ehemaligen Sportchef, der nach Vorwürfen sexueller Belästigung zurücktreten musste, müssen wir noch weiter zurückgehen? Da überlasse ich jetzt dir das Feld.
Ja, Marc Overmaas ist auf jeden Fall ein Stichwort. Ich glaube, insgesamt muss man sagen, ist in diesem Verein gar nicht so in einem Moment, sondern über die Jahre eine Unwucht entstanden. Das ist ein ganz interessantes Missverhältnis. Ajax selber wird von vielen neutralen Fans sehr modern wahrgenommen, weil sie z.B. ein extrem professionelles Marketing haben. Ich sage immer, die beste Social-Video-Abteilung der Welt. Es sind ja immer Gänsehaut-Videos. Manche finden sie zu kitschig. Aber wie sie sich auch von Spielern verabschieden, die den Verein verlassen, mit ganz viel Stil. Das Bob Marley-Trikot, das, glaube ich, 20-mal mehr verkauft wurde als ein normales Trikot. Ich glaube, ungefähr so ein Mokulus-Wert war für den Verein von den Einnahmen, keine Ahnung. Aber es hat auf jeden Fall was gebracht. Also da ist mit Menno Gehlen, heißt der Mann, ein totales Brain, der sich aber sehr auf Marketing konzentriert. Und der hat eben auch das, wofür Ajax steht, eben auch so ein bisschen monetarisiert und als Image transportiert. Hashtag for the future. In Wirklichkeit ist da aber ein, glaube ich, entsetzlich rückständiger Männerverein, in dem eben auch viel zu lange diese MeToo-Geschichten, die nicht nur Marc Overmars, sondern zum Beispiel auch sein, oder der kongeniale Co-Trainer Winston Bocharder, eine Ajax-Ikone aus der Van Raal-Mannschaft, ein super Abwehrtrainer, unter dem war die Abwehr stabil wie nie. Aber scheiß drauf, Entschuldigung, wenn ich das so sagen darf. Auch der Typ hat Frauen, mindestens eine Frau belästigt. Und das ist viel zu lange. Vom Aufsichtsrat, dem das bekannt war, und leider auch von Edwin van der Sar, dem CEO, geduldet worden. Warum? Weil Overmars mit dem Erfolg gleichgesetzt wurde. Overmars hat sich für Erik Tinhaag als Trainer starkgemacht, der ja keinen Stallgeruch hatte, was da immer so wichtig ist. Vielleicht vergleichbar mit Bayern München, muss man sagen. Ajax und Bayern, da gibt es viele Parallelen. Rekordmeister, die Ajax-Fans sagen quasi Miers a mi auf Niederländisch, Weiß sein Ajax, weiß sein de Beste –also wir sind Ajax, wir sind die Besten, wir sind arrogant, keiner mag uns, viele Parallelen. Und jetzt stellt ihr vor, jemand ohne Bayern-Bezug wurde da Trainer. Haben wir auch ein paar aktuelle Beispiele. Erik Tinhaag hatte am Anfang auch einen ganz schweren Start, hatte auch keinen Erfolg, spielte nicht schön. Aber Overmars hat gesagt, der wird es, habt Geduld. Overmars hat mit Dužan Tadic den Transfer des Jahrzehnts geholt, den er für, ich glaube, 20 Millionen aus Southampton geholt hat. Und das war als Kapitän spielerisch, aber auch von der Führerrolle in der Mannschaft der entscheidende Transfer. Dann die ganzen Talente, auch da war Overmars, hatte Overmars ein total gutes Gefühl, wie viele Spieler aus der Jugend nachkommen und wen man holen muss. Gleichzeitig, muss man aber sagen, wenn man sich einfach mal die Transfers auch unter Overmars anguckt, hat der ungefähr 30, 40 Prozent Trefferquote und der Rest, da waren absolute Schrotttransfers auch dabei. Aber wie das immer so ist, das wird dann verklärt bei den Fans. Ich glaube, da hat sich zu viel Macht um Overmars und seinen Herrenverein da gebildet. Und als dann der MeToo-Skandal kam, da hat man auch gesehen, dass das noch lange gearbeitet hat. Und das fiel in eine ganz, ganz blöde Phase, weil genau in der Zeit im Prinzip der Umbau, der richtige Umbau hätte passieren müssen. Eigentlich hätte Ajax alle Zeit der Welt gehabt. Es war klar, okay, Erik Denhaag hältst du jetzt nicht mehr. Der geht irgendwann zu einem großen Club. Dann wurde es manunited. Es war auch klar, dass bei Ajax quasi Folklore, dass diese ganzen Stars dann gewinnbringend verkauft werden. Das hätte man alles antizipieren können. Man hätte zum Beispiel früher Arne Slot, haben sich viele gewünscht, von Altmar ansprechen können. Den hat Feynort ihn dann weggeschnappt. Das wäre so sicherlich ein möglicher Nachfolger gewesen. Und plötzlich war Overmars weg. Und da war der arme Klaas-Jan Hüntelaar noch total unerfahren, quasi noch in der Ausbildung als Manager oder Sportdirektor. Und Geri Hamstra, die Holländen haben es dann Hamstelaar genannt, die sind als Duo aufgetreten. Und die hatten kein gutes Händchen. Also die aktuelle Ajax-Krise, da kann man zumindest den Fall Overmars als einen Startpunkt sehen, den Mitu-Skadal und den vergangenen Transfer, sagen wir schon. Also ich meine jetzt nicht vergangen in diesem Jahr, sondern 2022, 2023. Denn da sind so viele schlimme Sachen passiert. Und daran erkennt man auch, dass der Aufsichtsrat wirklich ein Problem hat. Ich will mal an zwei Anekdoten erinnern, die ihr vielleicht auch mitbekommen habt. Da haben wir zum einen Odysseas Lachodimos, der Torwart, der, glaube ich, mal beim VfB Stuttgart war und bei Benfica dann war. Ein super Torwart. Und den hätte Ajax haben können. Der wollte wohl auch zu Ajax für 12 Millionen Euro. Hünteler, Hamstra haben ihn überzeugt. Der damalige Trainer, Alfred Schröder, wollte den auch. Der hat erkannt, wir brauchen Torhüter. Unsere Torhüter sind alle gefühlt 45. Und dann hat der Aufsichtsrat gesagt, Ajax wird nie 12 Millionen Euro für einen Torwart bezahlt. Was eine total schwachsinn, also eine blöde, dogmatische Aussage ist. Transfer wurde verboten vom Aufsichtsrat. Wo eigentlich, einer der Hauptvorsitzenden, da ist ein ehemaliger Hockey-Weltmeister. Und deswegen wird er auch, die Niederländer sagen immer, der Hockey-Mann, so despektierlich. Erinnert ein bisschen an Hoffenheim, ne? Da war, glaube ich, auch der Bernhard Peters, oder wie? Gefährliches Hype-Wissen. Okay, also, die haben ganz viele –also, das war der eine Fall. Ich wollte noch die zweite Anekdote noch peinlicher erzählen. Lucas Ocampos, FC Sevilla, argentinischer Außenstürmer, sollte Ersatz für den weggegangenen Anthony sein. Anthony, trickreicher Spieler, extrem einflussreich, umstritten, nicht sehr beliebt bei gegnerischen Fans, aber eben für Ajax ein absolut wichtiger Spieler. Und da ist nicht so richtig Ersatz gekommen. Also sagt man, okay, wir holen jetzt noch diesen Ocampos. Dann ist er zur medizinischen Untersuchung nach Amsterdam gefahren. Die hat er bestanden. Und der Aufsichtsrat hat gesagt, nee, den verpflichten wir nicht. Wir sind von dem nicht überzeugt, zu teuer. Ocampos fliegt zurück nach Sevilla. Und dann haben der Trainer und Hündela und Hamstra den Aufsichtsrat bekniet, dass sie ihn wenigstens ausleihen dürfen. Es wurde sechs Stunden lang mit Sevilla verhandelt. Die beiden mussten nach Sevilla fliegen, sich beim Spieler entschuldigen. Und dann gab es auch kein ganz so großes Vorstellungsvideo vom Social-Video-Team. Dann ist Ocampos gekommen, hat, glaube ich, dreimal gespielt. Oba Pfeife bei Ajax mit Sevilla hat er dann im Europa Cup wieder super gespielt. Ich weiß nicht, ob er im Europa League-Finale auch getroffen hat, aber hat auf jeden Fall auch gespielt. Calvin Bessy haben die geholt. Calvin Bessy kennen zum Beispiel die Eintracht Frankfurt-Fans aus dem Finale gegen die Glasgow Rangers. Absolut ein Büffel oder ein Fels in der Brandung. Aber das Gegenteil von einem Ajax-Verteidiger. Ajax-Verteidiger sind immer schon seit Johann-Kreuz-Zeiten passstark, spielstark im Aufbauspiel. Sorry, Calvin Bessy ist ein wahnsinnig sympathischer Kämpfer, der auch Ajax liebt, aber ein absoluter Fehleinkauf. Ich könnte jetzt Name-Dropping ohne Ende machen. Das heißt, der Kader war falsch zusammengestellt. Alfred Schröder als Trainer hatte keinen Erfolg, war auch kein Menschenfänger, hat im Grunde auch nicht die Ajax-DNA, sondern Schröder wurde es vor allen Dingen deswegen, weil er langjähriger Assistent von Ten Haag war und wir alle gesagt haben, der kann am ehesten diese Spielidee fortsetzen. Hat aber nicht funktioniert und vielleicht der größte Fehleinkauf, und den wollte aber Overmaß schon, war Steven Bergwein. Oder wie meine kleine Tochter mal sagt, Beerschwein. Steven Bergwein kommt aus der Ajax Jugend, ist Amsterdamer, ist dann zu PSV gegangen, wurde da groß, ist zu den Tottenham Hotspurs gegangen und wurde dann für 25 Millionen Euro verpflichtet. Will links außen spielen? Auch diesen Transfer habe ich nicht verstanden, weil links außen war Dužan Tadic als Kapitän. Der Kapitän spielt immer. Berchwein will auch links außen spielen, obwohl er Rechtsfüßler ist, was auch ein Problem ist, weil er macht immer diesen Arjen Robben-Signature-Move, dass er dann nach innen zieht. Das kann er auch super gut, aber sonst, ehrlich gesagt, er hat nichts gebracht. Und dieser Berchwein ist jetzt aktueller Kapitän in der neuen Mannschaft. Er hat, glaube ich, zwei Tore gemacht für Ajax im ersten Spiel, aber im Prinzip ist er wirklich ein Totalausfall. Er hatte offenbar ein Riesenproblem mit Mislintat und hat auch Mitstimmung gemacht, möglicherweise auch Informationen an die Presse geleakt. Das weiß man aber nicht, das ist Spekulation, aber es gab diesen Instagram-Post des Vereins, bei dem die Entlassung von Mislintat bekanntgegeben wurde. Und der Edmund hat leider nicht darauf geachtet, die Gefällt-mir-Angaben auszublenden. Und es haben diverse aktuelle Spieler von Ajax –jetzt musst du dir mal überlegen, wie stillos das ist –den Post geliked, nämlich unter anderem Brian Robby, aber eben auch besagter Steven Bergwein. Und ja, also traurig.
Okay, das war jetzt ein Parforce-Rid durch die Transfers, die da nicht gut gelaufen sind. Dann lass doch mal über Sven Mislintat sprechen, weil er war ja dann derjenige, der quasi das übernehmen sollte und der ja aber mit Vorschusslobern gekommen ist, so wie er ja bisher immer mit Vorschusslobern kam. Ich glaube, jetzt so langsam dreht sich das so ein bisschen, weil die Vergangenheit von Sven Mislintat –wir haben da auch gestern in der Folge zum VfB Stuttgart ein bisschen drüber gesprochen –langsam erscheint zu manches in einem bisschen anderem Licht, weil de facto ist er jetzt bei mehreren Vereinen in Folge mehr oder weniger rausgeflogen. Wie hat er denn versucht, diesen schief zusammengestellten Kader zu flicken?
Ja, ich glaube, so wie er es immer macht, datenbasiert, evidenzbasiert, aber auch mit dem Bestreben, das würde ich ihm gar nicht absprechen, menschliche Komponenten, also charakterliche Eigenschaften und auch die Mischung im Team zu beachten. Er hat es aber –wenn wir schon vom Ende her denken –er hat es aber echt ziemlich alleine durchgezogen. Ich glaube, das wirkte für ihn vielleicht fast wie so ein Rausch. Ich habe ihn auch öfter mal bei Testspielen und Trainingsspiegeln beobachtet, da stand er immer wirklich mit dem Telefon am Ohr, telefonierend und so lächelnd und da dachte er, Ajax-Fans haben ja auch geschrieben, wer er jetzt wohl wiederholt. Bei der Mehrzahl der Fans, da müssen wir mal ansetzen, war das erstmal –das war quasi noch Edwin van der Sar's Entscheidung, Mislintat zu holen. Und van der Sar war da schon schwer angeschossen, aber da wurde gesagt, das ist jetzt mal echt ein interessanter Move. Die Niederländer haben gleich gesagt, der Datendeutsche kommt. Was bei Stuttgart passiert ist, ist auch so vielleicht seine mittelerfolgreiche Arsenal-Zeit, das wurde ausgeblendet. Es wurde eben gesagt, die Stuttgarter Erfolgstransfers wurden genannt, aber eben auch die Dortmunder Zeit. Und Mislintat steht eben für so eine Modernisierung oder den modernen Fußball, den viele Ajax-Fans sich dann auch wünschen. Also weg von diesem immer gleich –das ist so ambivalent in diesem Club. Johann Kreuf, Tradition, gleiches Trikot seit 50 Jahren, 433, Jugend, ja, aber man wünscht sich eine Erneuerung und man braucht sie auch, weil eben die Jugend auch nicht mehr so zuverlässig Riesentalente liefert. Und im Grunde die erste interessante Entscheidung von Mislintat war gar nicht eine Spielerentscheidung, sondern die Trainerentscheidung. Denn damals war John Heitinger ja noch Interimstrainer oder der war im Prinzip der Nachfolger von Schröder und er war auch nicht wirklich erfolgreich, ist ziemlich sang- und klanglos gegen Union Berlin aus der Europa League ausgeschieden, hat in der Liga die Champions League verpasst, also nicht er, sein Team, aber Heitinger und Heitinger hatte gute Momente und hat diesen Steilgeruch, kam von der Jugendmannschaft von Ajax als Trainer, aber so ganz überzeugt war er nicht. Und die Mehrheit der Fans hat Mislintat gelobt. Aber John Heitinger hat einen sehr einflussreichen Spielerberater und hat einen hervorragenden Draht zum Telegraph, zur Presse. Und man konnte damals schon, wenn man jetzt auch eine Archivrecherche macht, feststellen, dass die Boulevard-Medien erstaunlich negativ auf die Demission von –oder es war keine Demission, man hat einfach gesagt, lieber John, danke, super Vereinsikone, wir halten dich auch gerne für einen, aber du bist nicht der Cheftrainer. Mislintat hat gesagt, er glaubt, er traut ihm das nicht zu. Ajax braucht am besten auch einen ausländischen Trainer. Vielleicht einen niederländischen, vielleicht einen ausländischen Trainer. Und ab dann war schon das Sentiment negativ in der Presse. Gleichzeitig hat Mislintat aber auch immer wieder versucht, darauf hinzuweisen, ihr müsst mal Demut leeren. Wir haben die Champions League verpasst. Wir haben eine für die niederländischen Verhältnisse extreme Gehaltsstruktur. Das kann man nicht mit der Bundesliga vergleichen. Ajax ist ein reicher Club, aber die Champions League, also die Nichtqualifikation für die Champions League, hat Ajax circa 40 Millionen gekostet. Die Mannschaft war eh schon relativ teuer. Dujan Tadic hatte, glaube ich, einen Gehalt von 6 Millionen Euro mit seinen 34. Das ist für einen Ehredivisie-Club wirklich sehr, sehr viel Geld. Und Mislintat hat gesagt, wir müssen uns gesund schrumpfen. Und mit den Voraussetzungen wird es nicht gehen, wie die Ajax-Fans sich das wünschen, oder die Boulevardpresse, dass man lauter Stars holt. Die Boulevardpresse hat dann so selber Tabloß aufgestellt. Ja, Mislintat, mein Eindruck hat sich immer weiter ins Schneckenhaus zurückgezogen, hat einfach selber, wie bei Fußballmanager 23, seinen Traumkader zusammengestellt. Aber alleine. Er hat einfach offenbar gar nicht mehr auf den Trainer gehört. Den Trainer, den er selbst ausgesucht hat. Und ich sag mal so, am Anfang war da noch so eine gewisse Euphorie, aber dann kam Fragezeichen auf. Zum Beispiel beim Transfer von Ramay, von Eintracht Frankfurt, den wirklich keiner kannte, wo auch bis heute unterschiedliche Ablösesummen kolportiert werden. Ich glaube, 8 Millionen stehen da im Raum für den Nachwuchs. Reserve-Torwart von Eintracht Frankfurt, das hat gar niemand verstanden. Es sind viele Spieler verkauft worden, das hat er gut gemacht, das wurde ihm auch positiv angerechnet. Er hat wirklich tolle Ablösesummen erzielt, er hat im Prinzip fast alle Stars verkauft, musste er auch, weil die auch weg wollten. Aber er hat eine wirklich sehr obscure Auswahl von High Potentials aus den zweiten Ligen in Frankreich, aus den dänischen Ligaspieler geholt, fast nur No-Names für relativ hohe Ablösesummen. Ajax hat auch über 110 Millionen Euro ausgegeben, das ist auch eine Menge Geld. Er hat immer gesagt, und da bin ich Mislintat, er hat erst mal rechtgemerkt, er hat gesagt, ihr könnt mich gerne kritisieren, aber im November oder Dezember, ihr könnt doch jetzt nicht neu zugänglich schlecht machen nach fünf Spielen. Genau das hat aber sein eigener Trainer gemacht, öffentlich. Genau, Maurice Stein, den hat er geholt, der war vorher bei Sparta Rotterdam. Maurice Stein ist ein sehr interessanter Trainer, der immer –Mislintat hat es so gesagt –der immer overperformed hat bei seinen Clubs. Also die Clubs haben den Haag und Sparta Rotterdam haben unter ihm signifikant gut gespielt und bessere Ergebnisse erreicht. Dazu ist er ein eigentlich sympathischer, offener Typ, deutlich charismatischer als z.B. Schröder oder Heitinger. Das hat Mislintat erkannt. Interessant war, dass die Boulevardpresse die ganze Zeit auch eine andere Geschichte vorangetrieben hat, dass er nämlich unbedingt den Trainer von Bodo Glimt holen will. Ich glaube, Gschetel Knutzen heißt der Mann, diesen Wunderverein da aus Nord-Norwegen. Mislintat hat sich dazu nie geäußert. Und dann hieß es schon, Morris Zain ist wohl nur zweite Wahl. Also das war auch schon so ein bisschen komisch. Aber auf jeden Fall. Also ich vermute, Mislintat –und das ist jetzt bitte Spekulation –Mislintat hat auch einen Trainer gesucht, der unter ihm Trainer ist. Der akzeptiert, pass auf, ich hole dich zum großen Club, Morris, du kannst hier machen, aber ich bin der Kalaplaner. Also ich alleine bediene den Fußballmanager 23. Und du hast nichts zu sagen. Und wenn das so war, muss man sagen, trifft hier Mislintat natürlich eine ganz große Schuld. Weil selbst wenn er vielleicht total viel Ahnung hat und die besten Talente Europas kennt, bringt das ja überhaupt nichts gegen den Willen und die Spielphilosophie eines Trainers zu handeln. Und es gibt einen Namen, an dem man das, glaube ich, ganz gut verdeutlichen kann, dass Mislintat vielleicht auch hätte Kompromisse eingehen können und sollen. Ajax hatte ein Problem auf der linksverteidiger Position, weil sowohl Owen Weindahl, der ein Jahr vor von Aset Altma gekommen ist, als auch der talentierte Anas Salah-Edin aus der eigenen Jugend, der war Antwente Falin, nicht wirklich die Qualitäten mitgebracht haben, sowohl im Aufbauspiel, aber vor allen Dingen im Defensivverhalten, die Ajax brauchte. Und es hätte wahrscheinlich die Möglichkeit gegeben, einen alten Bekannten zurückzuholen. Nico Taliafico, Argentinier, Kämpferherz, der das ein oder andere Mal blutend vom Feld gegangen ist oder vom Feld gezerrt werden musste, weil er weiterspielen wollte. Der ist zu Lyon gegangen, der wollte zu Ajax zurück. Maurice Stein hat mehrfach auch öffentlich gesagt, dass er das sehr begrüßen würde. Die Fans lieben Nico Taliafico. Er wäre auch bezahlbar gewesen. Ist das mal so, stattdessen spielen jetzt auf links Borna Sosa und Gaston Avila, den man von Antwerpen geholt hat, der auch nicht billig war. Borna Sosa, sicherlich auch ein guter Spieler, aber dieser Transfer könnte dann noch juristische Folgen haben für Sven Mislintat und die Frage, wie sein Arbeitsverhältnis beendet werden kann. Denn spätestens das hat dann das fast zum Überlaufen gebracht. Es gibt den Verdacht, oder es ist wahrscheinlich sogar schon ziemlich sicher, dass das ein Fakt ist, dass Borna Sosa kurz vor dem Transfer oder im Zuge des Transfers den Spielerberater gewechselt hat und dass die neue Agentur wiederum wirtschaftliche Beziehungen hat zu der Firma Match Matrix, bei der wiederum Sven Mislintat Anteile hat. Das heißt, es ist ein klarer Interessenskonflikt, wenn auch nur ein Cent Provision für einen Transfer indirekt an ihn geht. Ich glaube, es ist juristisch und nach den UEFA-Statuten wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal verboten. Aber es ist klar, nach dem Ajax-Kodex ein Problem. Und Mislintat war schon vor seiner richtigen Entlassung freigestellt. Er sollte nicht mehr ins Stadion kommen. Er war quasi suspendiert. Also es ist eine ganz komplizierte Geschichte. Ja, ich habe jetzt so viel geredet.
Um noch mal kurz das zu verdeutlichen, auch das werden ja nicht alle Hörerinnen und Hörer mitbekommen haben. Also Bonas Sosa war quasi schon im Wechsel begriffen. Und dann hat eben Sven Mislintat eine Berateragentur mandatiert. Das macht man durchaus. Manchmal ist es immer schon eine umstrittene Praxis, weil sich die Frage stellt, wenn sich alle Parteien einig sind, warum muss man da jetzt noch mal jemanden beauftragen. Aber das ist jetzt nicht so unüblich im Fußball. Und diese Berateragentur, die hält eben auch Anteile an Matchmatrix. Das ist eine Firma, an der auch Sven Mislintat beteiligt ist. Das heißt, jetzt einen direkten Geldfluss hätte es da nie gegeben. Aber natürlich schon ein Interessenskonflikt. Und das ist auch vielleicht nicht unüblich in der Fußballbranche, aber schon bemerkenswert naiv, das so zu machen. Vor allem, wenn man auch schon so in der Kritik steht. Also es spricht vielleicht auch für etwas, was wir sonst manchmal bei Sven Mislintat gesehen haben. Du hast gesagt, er zieht sich in sein Schneckenhaus zurück. Im Guten kann man sagen, er ist dann immun gegen Kritik. Im Schlechten könnte man sagen, er ist da auch nicht kompromissbereit und vielleicht auch nicht vorsichtig genug. Und in dem Fall hat er sich angreifbar gemacht. Das öffentlich-rechtliche Fernsehen in den Niederlanden hat das aufgedeckt. Daraufhin wurde er suspendiert, durfte keinen Kontakt mehr zur Mannschaft haben, durfte nicht mehr aufs Trainingsgelände. Auch das kennen wir schon aus der Vergangenheit von Sven Mislintat, wenn auch aus anderen Gründen, aber bemerkenswerte Parallele. Und jetzt war das vielleicht dann eben dann, dass der Tropfen, der das fast zum Überlaufen gebracht hat, vielleicht auch die günstige Möglichkeit, sich von jemandem zu trennen, der dann auch ein bisschen eine Sündenbock-Rolle einnehmen kann?
Ich finde auf jeden Fall auch, dass er ein Sündenbock ist. Also man kann ihm ganz klar Dinge vorwerfen. Das ist fast schon ein Fazit, aber ich würde sagen, eigentlich ist Sven Mislintat genau der richtige Mann, aber der Club ist nicht bereit. Und Sven Mislintat ist so intelligent, das weiß ich. Das merkt man in Interviews in seiner Handlungsweise. Es ist ein hochintelligenter Mensch, der auch, glaube ich, psychologische Qualitäten hat. Aber was er einfach überhaupt nicht verstanden hat, ist, dass er so einen Traditionsverein mitnehmen muss. Und das natürlich auch komisch ist, Ajax lebt natürlich auch von niederländischen Talenten und auch niederländischen Spielern. Die können auch mal aus Alkmaar oder Utrecht kommen. Aber er hat einen einzigen Niederländer geholt, mit Branko van den Boom. Okay, den hat er für 0 Euro bekommen aus Toulouse. Super Transfer. Aber das macht die Sache nicht leichter, dem Trainer gar keinen Wunsch zu erfüllen. Das ist unnötig. Und insgesamt war sein Auftreten auch so, auch wie er auf der Tribüne saß. Er hat sich da so ein bisschen gehen lassen. Ajax ist ja eher auch so ein mondäner Verein. Also das ganze Auftreten durfte eigentlich nicht entscheidend sein. Das hat aber alles dazu beigetragen.
Das ist jetzt die Teamkose von Jürgen Klopp, die ihn im HSV gebracht hat. So ein bisschen.
Ja, also wenn über Mislintat geschrieben wird, dann teilen die meisten Ajax-Fans immer nur einen Surf-Brett, den grünen Surf-Emoji irgendwie. Also eigentlich hat er so ein Kult-Image. Manche haben sich auch über ihn lustig gemacht. Aber auch jetzt, nach seiner Entlassung, sagen viele, sie hätten sich gewünscht, dass Maurice Stein geht. Weil also eins war klar, man muss sagen, der Vorstand musste handeln. Die Leistungen der Mannschaft sind desaströs. Und Maurice Stein hat teilweise auch wirklich ganz offensichtlich Spieler-Aufstellungen gegen Sven Mislintat getroffen, um dem zu zeigen, ich nehme deine Neuzugänge nicht. Das ist wirklich, also erinnert an Szenen im Sandkasten, wenn die Kinder sich mit Förmchen bewerfen. Aber doch nicht auf Kosten von so einem Club in so einer sportlichen Krise. Neben dem Klassiker, da hat er diesen jungen Guy, den Dänen, der mir wahnsinnig leid tut. Also die Mitspieler haben den auch in den Arm genommen. Armer Junge, was für ein Trauma, sein erstes großes Spiel der Klassiker. Und dann wird das Spiel abgebrochen. Ich weiß nicht, wie es dem geht. Ich hoffe, der ist mental stabil. Wirklich furchtbar, der wurde dann ganz früh gegen Rentsch ausgewechselt. Und auf der anderen Seite zur Pause nimmt er dann Borna Sosa raus. Der, finde ich, noch einer der besseren war in einem so mittel… Also es war auch nicht furchtbar, das Spiel gegen Feyenoord. Es gab auch lichte Momente, aber okay, der nimmt Borna Sosa raus. Dann hätte jeder erwartet, dass er den Avila bringt. Den Mislintat hat auch geholt, der kampfstarke Argentinier, weil es fehlte an Kampf und Körperlichkeit gegen Feyenoord und vor allen Dingen an defensiver Stärke. Und wem bringt er? Anas Salaheddin, der vorher schon da war und der einfach praktisch, ich glaube seine ersten fünf Pässe waren Fehlpässe und haben Feyenoord dann… Also gut, dass das Spiel abgebrochen wurde, ich sage es mal so, sonst wäre es wahrscheinlich 0 zu 5 ausgegangen. Das waren so Entscheidungen. Oder in einem anderen Spiel hat er einfach ohne Rechtsaußen gespielt. So aus Protest, weil er hat das auch in der Presse gesagt, ich verstehe nicht, warum Mislintat keinen Rechtsaußen geholt hat. Sie haben Concesaro verkauft, sie haben Mourkoudos verkauft und dann wollte Steyn, wen auch immer, das weiß ich nicht, einen neuen Rechtsaußen haben. Mislintat hat gesagt, ich habe polyvalente Außenstürmer, die wie Forbes, der vielleicht der interessanteste und beste Neuzugang ist, der links wie rechts spielen kann. Steyn sieht das offenbar nicht so und hat dann einfach mal in einem Ligaspiel, nämlich gegen Twente, ohne Rechtsaußen praktisch gespielt. Also Truba Akbom hat dann so eine verschobene Szenen gespielt mit katastrophalen Folgen, weil dann die rechte Seite defensiv überlaufen wurde. Also das muss man eben auch sehen und als Ajax-Fan wünsche ich mir persönlich, obwohl ich Maurice Steyn am Anfang total sympathisch fand, ich finde das so dermaßen illoyal und so ein egoistisches Verhalten, dass ich persönlich sehr hoffe, dass er auch bald gehen muss. Und wenn wir nach vorne blicken, es gibt einen großen Hoffnungsschimmer.
Warte ganz kurz, vor dem Hoffnungsschimmer. Weil eine Sache verstehe ich ganz grundsätzlich nicht. Wenn der Aufsichtsrat vorher immer so wichtig war und zum Teil ja in bemerkenswert komischer Art und Weise Transfers abgesegnet hat, warum durfte dann jetzt Mislintat machen, wie er wollte?
Durfte er nicht tatsächlich. Also es gab auch zwei Transfers, wo der Aufsichtsrat sich eingemischt hat. Mislintat hatte einen Wunschstürmer für die Nummer 10-Position, ein Armenier mit russischen Wurzeln, der heißt Eduard Sperzjan, und den wollte er haben. Der spielt bei Krasnodar. Krasnodar ist ein Verein in Russland. Der Präsident ist wohl auch als Oligarch eng mit Putin befreundet. Und Mislintat hat gesagt, wir werden einen Weg finden, diesen Transfer sanktionskonform abzuwickeln, nämlich dass Sperzjan sich selber auslöst. Und den hat er nicht bekommen. Der Aufsichtsrat hat gesagt, nein, Ajax steht für ethische Werte, die sich nicht damit vertragen, mit Transfers Putin zu unterstützen. Und Mislintat hat wohl auch sehr lange gerungen, dass er den teuersten Neuzugang bekommt, nämlich Josep Šutalo, kroatischer Nationalverteidiger. Bisher hat man davon noch nicht so viel gemerkt, leider, aber ich glaube an ihn. Der ist von Dynamo Zagreb gekommen, für 20 Millionen Euro. Und da hieß es wohl auch vom Aufsichtsrat, also es war wohl sehr, sehr hart. Und da war es wohl mal einer der wenigen Transfers, wo Steyn und Mislintat sich einig waren. Aber du hast recht, der Aufsichtsrat, wo ist eigentlich der Aufsichtsrat, wenn man ihn braucht? Der Aufsichtsrat hätte auf jeden Fall, also vor allen Dingen der Sportdirektor Hendrix, der hätte auf jeden Fall auch intervenieren müssen und Mislintat sagen müssen so, Sven, du bist hier nicht, weißt was, ich, bei Fußballmanager und du bist auch halt nicht beim VfB Stuttgart, sondern wir sind hier beim niederländischen Traditionsverein und da gibt es, kannst du nicht alles mal, du kannst nicht Ajax Amsterdam in einem Transfer so mal auf den Kopf stellen. So und die gucken sich auch alle der Zerby und Breiten an und so finden das ganz cool und das haben viele Ajax-Fans so gesehen. Ja, wir werden ein Datenclub, aber nein, das ist einfach so ein Hau-Ruck-Umbau, das ist einfach nicht machbar und trotzdem wahnsinnig bitter natürlich, weil ich meine, er wird jetzt natürlich auch um die möglichen Früchte seiner Arbeit gebracht. Ein Tweet von gestern war, angenommen Stain wird entlassen, der Trainer, es kommt ein neuer Trainer, alle Neuzugänge performen, holen wir dann Sven im Januar zurück, hat einer geschrieben. Das ist ja wirklich, ne?
Und er war ja nur für vier Monate da. Also das ist ja geradezu bizarr oder nur für wenige Monate, war es mit Mislintat da. Eigentlich kann die Arbeit eines Kaderplaners und Sportvorstands kann dann ja gar nicht funktionieren in diesem kurzen Zeitraum. Aber ich denke, wir haben ganz gut verstanden, warum so viele Dinge zueinander gekommen sind, dass man da jetzt auch handeln musste. Und deswegen würde ich jetzt dann nämlich ganz gerne zum Hoffnungsschimmer kommen. Wer ist denn diese magische Gestalt, die in dieser dunklen Nacht bei Ajax –ich habe gelesen, wenn es bleibt bei diesen fünf Punkten aus dann fünf Spielen, wenn man dieses Spiel gegen Feyenoord noch verliert, dann ist das der schlechteste Start seit 60 Jahren. Also das ist wirklich historisch schlecht. Wer hat diese Strahlkraft, da jetzt einen Hoffnungsschimmer zu senden?
Ja, der Mann heißt Alex Kroes, also wenn ihr ihn googelt, das ist niederländisch K-R-O-E-S geschrieben und kommt von AZ. Und AZ Alkuma ist manchmal jetzt so das bessere Ajax geworden. AZ hat unter anderem, obwohl viele den Club gar nicht so richtig auf dem Schirm hatten, die UEFA Youth League gewonnen. Eine fantastische Jugendarbeit. AZ holt regelmäßig wirklich sehr günstig gute Spieler aus dem In- und Ausland. Die haben genau diese Balance. Sie holen sich auch Talente aus der niederländischen 2. Liga. ALKMA ist ja viel kleiner, ist ja nördlich, an der Nordsee mehr oder weniger, nicht so weit von Amsterdam. Und dieser Alex Kroos, der ist heute noch –ich glaube, die Posten heißen –internationale Strategie. Aber er gilt sozusagen als das Brain. Er hat auch schon mit Arne Slott, der jetzt super erfolgreich bei Feyenoord ist, zusammengearbeitet. Und Ajax wollte den nicht gehen lassen, was ein sehr gutes Zeichen ist. Am Ende hat man dann gesagt, okay, Alex Kroos will zu Ajax, Ajax will in. Ajax hat jetzt –oder Kroos soll jetzt 50.000 Euro für die Jugendstiftung von AZ spenden. Und aufgrund seines Vertrages hat er ja noch eine Sperrfrist. Vielleicht lässt AZ ihn früher gehen, um den holländischen Fußball zu retten. Und Ajax –ich glaube, um den 15. März kommenden Jahres soll er neuer CEO, also neuer Geschäftsführer werden. Damit im Grunde der richtige Nachfolger von Edwin van der Sar. Denn jetzt ist es Jan van Halst. Der war vorher im Aufsichtsrat und oh Gott, der macht keine gute Figur. Ich beneide ihn auch nicht, aber der ist unsicher in seinen Statements. Der Verein hat ein desaströses Auftreten jetzt auch nach dem abgebrochenen Klassiker. Das ist überhaupt nicht ajaxwürdig und indirekt kritisieren ihn dann auch Ikonen wie Louis van Gaal. Van Gaal war übrigens für viele auch für mich sozusagen die Wunschlösung, weil ich hätte mir eher die Meldung erhofft, Maurice Dein muss gehen nach diesem Klassiker und nicht Sven Mislintat muss gehen und Louis van Gaal hat kategorisch ausgeschlossen. Es wurde sogar kolportiert, dass ihn auch tatsächlich der DFB angefragt habe. Da habe er auch abgesagt aus gesundheitlichen Gründen und er wird bei Ajax definitiv leider nicht Trainer. Ich glaube, er wäre als Interimstrainer ziemlich gut und interessant.
Wobei er doch den Kader auch so laut kritisiert hat, oder? Habe ich das nicht mal gelesen, dass Louis van Gaal auch einer derjenigen war, der gesagt hat, was macht denn Mislintat da mit diesem Kader?
Ja, aber ich glaube trotzdem, dass er am Ende die so ähnlich, wie er es auch bei Oranje bei der Elftal gemacht hat, ich glaube, er hätte die schon gut zusammengestellt und auch diese Ajax-Grundwerte beigebracht. Weil der Kader ist nicht so schlecht. Also, ehrlich, ein Bornars Hoser, das ist ja das Interessante. Bei all den Umständen, wie geht es eigentlich Bornars Hoser? Ich meine, es ist Mislintat, wie viele andere übrigens auch, Juba Akbom, der Neuner, der Ersatz für Brian Borbiet, Tor-Schützenkönig in der zweiten englischen Liga. Der sagte im ersten Interview –ich bin nur wegen Sven Mislintat hier –der wollte mich damals per Arsenal schon groß rausbringen und er hat mich überzeugt, zu Ajax zu kommen. Mislintat ist weg. Mikao Daze, 16 Millionen Euro, Georgier mit Französischer Franco Georgier, der aus Metz kam, nur wegen Mislintat gekommen. Also da sind jetzt mindestens fünf, sechs Spieler, die quasi direkt von ihm angelockt wurden. Ajax kann sich wirtschaftlich gar nicht leisten, diese ganzen Neuzugänge jetzt liegenzulassen. Und die werden, ich bin mir ganz sicher, nicht jeder Mislintat-Transfer wird zünden. Das war in Stuttgart auch nicht so und bei Arsenal schon gar nicht und auch beim BVB sicher nicht. Aber man kann ganz klar sagen, also ich bin mir hundertprozentig sicher, der Forbes, der wird ein kommender Weltstar. Das wird der nächste 100 Millionen Euro-Transfer von Ajax. Das siehst du jetzt schon. Der Typ ist, der läuft mit Tempo 200, die Linie lang dribbelt. Er ist ein fantastischer Spieler, kleinwendig, genauer ein typischer Ajax-Außenstürmer übrigens. Und du erkennst eben auch, welche Qualität Borna Sosa offensiv hat. Und bei dem Schutalow, bei dem Kroaten, da hoffen wir wirklich, dass er die Abwehr stabilisiert. Also ich glaube, Alex Cruz wird als CEO erst mal Ruhe in den Verein bringen. Ajax wird mindestens, also dieses Jahr ist sowieso, die Holländer sagen immer so schön geschrieben, es ist ein Übergangsjahr für Ajax. Ich glaube, wir werden eher drei Übergangsjahre haben. Ajax braucht jetzt Demut und zum Glück, und das hat Mislintat geschafft, sie haben eine Gehaltsstruktur, die es ihnen auch ermöglicht, noch mal die Champions League zu verpassen. Weil eins ist ganz klar, schon jetzt nach dem Saisonstart, Ajax wird mit der Meisterschaft nichts zu tun haben. Die werden Feyenoord und PSV mutmaßlich unter sich ausspielen. Und ich kann mir auch gut vorstellen, dass es, je nachdem wer Trainer ist, auch im nächsten Jahr noch nicht alles super wird. Aber Ajax wird wieder seriöser werden unter Cruz. Die Jugend wird wieder einen größeren Stellenwert haben. Und dann kann man auch langfristig wieder sehr erfolgreich sein. Denn es gibt auch jetzt wieder ein paar riesen Talente, die jetzt auch schon in der Mannschaft spielen. Und vielleicht stärkt ja auch diese Krisenerfahrung.
Ach, es ist schon interessant, welche Geschichten der Fußball schreibt. Und es ist jetzt ein bisschen schade, dass wir über die vielen positiven Geschichten der Eredivision jetzt nicht sprechen konnten. Wir haben uns jetzt hier auf das Problemkind, ich sag's einfach mal, gestürzt über PSV, über Alkmaar, über Enschede, glaube ich, könnte man viel erzählen. Feyenoord ja auch. Nicht zuletzt, also das war jetzt nicht total überraschend, dass die 3-0 führen zum Zeitpunkt des Abbruchs in diesem Klassiker. Das müssen wir vielleicht mal wannanders im Rasenfunk machen. Ich verfolge die Eredivision immer schon über euren Account und immer so aus einem Augenwinkel. Ich schaffe es bisher nicht, es regelmäßig reinzuholen. Aber es ist ganz klar mein Versäumnis. Du hast mich richtig angefixt. Ich hätte jetzt richtig Bock, noch eine Stunde weiterzureden. Aber das machen wir vielleicht mal wannanders, Benni, wenn du dann mehr Zeit hast, wenn dann vielleicht noch jemand anders von Oranje Fußball mit dazu kommen kann. Ich danke dir sehr, dass du dir die Zeit genommen hast, sehr spontan ja auch für den Rasenfunk. Ja, und dann bin ich sehr gespannt, wie es weitergeht bei Ajax. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörern, danke ich auch. An dieser Stelle der Hinweis, der Rasenfunk ist allein crowdfinanziert. Keine Werbung, keine Sponsoren, keine Paywall. Auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclub.deerfahrtihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann. Und ihr könnt das gerne nach dem Value for Value Prinzip machen. Also was hat so eine Sendung für einen Gegenwert für euch? Und dann überweist ihr uns und dann können wir nämlich dafür sorgen, dass es mehr solcher Sendungen gibt. Vielleicht gibt es ja mal noch einen weiteren Moderator, Moderatorin hier, dann gibt es auch mehr Ehre, die Wüste.
Das war der Rasenfunk. Von Ihnen unterstützt.